dilma bonjour alors on le voit un
plusieurs dizaines de manifestants
derrière vous rassembler malgré
l'interdiction
oui ils sont rassemblés ils sont venus
malgré cette interdiction un peu pour un
cortège qui devait donc partir ici
depuis la place du palais royal devant
le conseil d'état et vous avez vous
l'avez dit qu'ils devaient ensuite se
diriger vers le sénat pour le moment au
cortège il n'y a pas tout ce qui lie à
ce son c'est un dispositif très
important des forces de l'ordre qui nas
et les manifestants puis qui ensuite les
europe ou sur la place les manifestants
qui avaient commencé à se diriger sur la
rue saint-honoré donc dans une dans un
début de manifestation sauvage qui ont
été arrêtés à la fin de cette quelques
semaines ou quelques centaines de mètres
plus loin dans cette rue saint-honoré
avant de refluer d'être repoussée il ya
eu d'ailleurs quelques échauffourées
dans s'il vous plaît monsieur pardon il
ya eu quelques échauffourées
messieurs s'il vous plaît merci c'est
gentil il ya eu quelques est fou
d'échauffourées avec les manifestants
quelques grenades lacrymogènes qui ont
été d'ailleurs tiré vous l'avez vu
peut-être sur les images précédemment
une menace très étroit qui s'est formée
mais des nas qui sont en réalité assez
inefficace puisque certains manifestants
partent ensuite sur la place avant de
revenir et de repartir il ya ainsi un un
jeu de chat et de la souris qui s'est
mis en place avec avec les forces de
l'ordre qui ont un petit peu du mal à
contenir à contenir cette manifestation
cette mobilisation donc de cet acte 64
et qui a été en plus venus dénoncer
justement le manque de dialogue avec le
gouvernement et l'emploi qu'il juge
abusif justement des delà de la force de
la violence et je suis avec eric donc
merci eric de répondre à nos questions
qui est là depuis depuis le début de
cette manifestation alors bon c'est
l'ailé il ya eu quelques échauffourées
comment est ce que vous sentez un petit
peu l'ambiance et si surtout est-ce
qu'il ya pas une contradiction avec
justement est ce que dénonçait les
gilet jaune escape à un congrès c'est ce
que c'est pas un comble de voir comme ça
c'est complet des forces de l'ordre
écoutez moi tout ce que je vois c'est
des gens un peu calme comme moi moi je
viens de provins je viens d'assez loin
donc à chaque fois je suis toujours
étonné entre ben la police qui
aujourd'hui est plus nombreuses que les
manifestants et puis il ya des
manifestants qui s'est relativement bon
enfant général alors suis toujours
étonné voilà un peu déçue même mais bon
voilà
et est ce que vous êtes venus manifester
malgré l'interdiction donc pourtant il
ya eu des menaces d'amande pour ceux qui
venaient manifester
est ce que vous comptez comme ça
continue à venir manifester par exemple
s'il ya d'autres manifestations même
interdite par la préfecture
alors je vais vous dire je regarde même
pas si c'est interdit ou pas pourtant je
suis un honnête citoyen mais bon là je
voulais soutenir les gilet jaune je suis
professeur donc pour moi c'est le même
combat que ce soit interdit ou pas
interdit je remercie merci d'avoir
répondu à nos questions
donc on dit toujours là sur l'abstrait
place du palais royal devant le conseil
d'état
lieu symbolique puisqu'en plus le
conseil d'état cela était dit avait
refusé de suspendre l'emploi duel bd en
février 2019
la haute juridiction avait été saisie
par la cgt la cgt qui demandait
justement la suspension de cet emploi le
conseil d'état a refusé pour le moment
mais écoutez il ya toujours autant de
forces de l'ordre est ce que la
manifestation va se disperser totalement
est ce que les manifestants vont se
regrouper pour suivre le cortège qui
était initialement prévu ou est ce
qu'ils vont repartir comme cela a été le
cas sur un autre axe afin de continuer à
manifester en cette action 64 qui pour
le moment ne respecte pas le en tout cas
ne suis pas le trajet qui avait été
initialement prévu c'est ce que nous
verrons cours d'année des prochaines
minutes
merci beaucoup guillemat pour toutes ces
précisions on vous retrouve un tout au
long de l'après midi qu'il marosi en
direct du conseil d'état à paris et puis